hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast metagenomics influencing
agriculture environment and more I'm
Robert castellanos elaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by alumina at illumina we
apply innovative technologies for
studying genetic variations and function
making studies possible that were not
even imaginable just a few years ago
these revolutionary tools for DNA and
RNA analysis are enabling rapid advances
in disease research drug development and
development a molecular test in the
clinic Elena's innovative sequencing and
array technologies are fueling
groundbreaking and advancements in life
science research translation and
customer genomics and molecular
diagnostics for more information please
visit Illumina com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window and submit your problem through
the green Q&A button lower left this is
a chanel webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. quote I'm killing over the
last four years dr. Keeling has served
as a marketing manager specializing in
microbiology at the Illumina
headquarters in San Diego California
chance began her career as a research
scientist and
3 matrix with a degree in biology from
the University of Denver and spent many
years in product development
additionally in the last seven years dr.
ting Ling has been marking in marketing
roles where she developed special
interest and focus on micro biomes and
metagenomics I will now turn it over to
dr. keeling for a presentation thank you
thank you for joining me today our
project today is focused on how much I
genomic is changing the way we study
culture agriculture the environment and
everything around us I will absolutely
touch on three different subjects and
different studies on with a genomic and
how important it is in those three
different subjects so one of them is
water source and water resources animal
and also agriculture before I start to
go deep into metagenomic I wanted to
present the my secret film and this is a
small sequencer it is designed to
actually use directly after your library
preparation with preparation single
sample or actually miss multiplex
samples can be loaded in the
pre-configured region cast cartridge the
consumables required for for a single
run is a so cell and a reagent cartridge
and buffa borrow all the reagents needed
for clustering generation and sequencing
for single or care than our pre elevated
into the agent cartridges the run setup
is fast and efficient each consumable
are tagged and so it's easy to do the
through the tracking and traceability
I'm going to go through onto 16s rrna
sequencing it's the end-to-end solution
that we have and
from the sample instruction with episode
I epicentre a kiss to our protocol v3 v4
a region is a [ __ ] onto that
protocol but it also shows you how to
use and primers then you can actually do
the library press using multiple and s's
all the way to 384 putting it on the
mighty like I said earlier and then do
data analysis with different application
one of them is the 16s app which is
available but you have multiple choices
on on on base base so to go a little
deeper on the 16s protocol there's the
protocols details to use v3 v4 as the
primer sequences but the user can choose
any combination of primers and and use
the the database of 16s in other ethnic
on if they want to and create an ethic
on with a 50 base fare overlap when your
sequence so that you can really use the
2 by 2 50 or two by three hundred run
flow of the my seat if you can actually
analyze it with a metagenomic workflow
on on em I see with MSR version 2.3 or
base plate with it it is also available
there the suspect that are followed are
doing the primer the is the first
amplification of v3 v4 or any other epic
on that you wish followed by the library
prep doing the next day or XP and then
you add the indices for you to be able
to multiply all the way to 3 384 but you
can also do 90
this who usually there is for kids up
ninety six different primers that you
can use the my seat actually generates
enough read that you can do at least 96
samples but even more because you get it
about a hundred thousand coverage by
doing anything samples even in n more
the analysis is easy I've been talked
about the 16s up but you could
definitely also use chime which is
available on base base metal on up there
crackin and other 16s or metagenomic
applications or software so the primary
says that we actually have our the
following with the forward and the
reverse those are great apparatus
primers that we that we actually use the
in this protocol but you can definitely
use any kind of others this one was
published in the Kenworth publication of
2013 the paper is called evaluation of
general 16s rrna gene pcr primers for
classical and legs and aeration
sequencing-based diversity studies it
has an overhang nucleotide sequence that
as a gene specific sequence and the full
length of the primer sequence use the
defenders i do PhD nucleotide
nomenclature to follow the protocol of
the start targeting this region so you
can definitely use your local specific
sequence and all you would have to do is
add the overhang adapter to them this is
very well explained in the protocol the
first pcr which is the locus specific
pcr well actually do the following right
edge to the genomic DNA and then that
surprises it's actually is a very small
cycle pcr then you have a second-round
pcr with the next era and X primers to
get your final product for you to be
able to put it on the mighty system but
regardless of your study really when
you're doing with a genomic you're
always asking the same question the
first one is what type of micro organism
are present and the second question is
always how abundant are they and then
the next question is well what's the
function what are they doing how are the
influencing other microbes in this
environment or in human cells and and
then how does the environment change
structure or function of the organism is
on so it doesn't matter whether it's oil
or water there is also there's always
the same questions that come up or or
human health so a metagenomic project
always starts by 16s you know you really
want to know the relative abundance of
the classification and the
high-resolution phylogeny but then the
next step is always wait a minute I want
to do a shotgun with is no big run so
that I can see the gene expression
analysis and and the functionality of
those markets that are there and then
that's money even enough because those
are just the DNA you might want to go to
my pet transcriptomics because you want
to see the RNA that is produced in that
sample and then they come up with a
signature profile to a specific
environment that actually changes every
single time depending on what is
happening in the environment and then
another way to look at it is with long
weeks conference so i'm not going to go
really deep into this but by adding
another kid called to speak long wait
for example you could definitely define
some superior is peculiar this area in
your cell phone and and be completely
set on how on how its set up and how I
look so a message anomic study is not
only 16 s is what I really wanted to say
so I'm going to talk about this project
that was done a while ago with IUPUI on
on water sources Eagle Creek a reservoir
is a drinking supply for Indianapolis
Indiana this this area or this reservoir
actually experiences a seasonal blooming
of cannabis area in the reservoir and
subsequently the drinking water out of
the oven Annapolis of Fisheries exactly
Indiana it has this unpleasant taste and
order and and you can you can taste it
and so we were trying to find the
association between the algae blooms
that is happening in that reservoir and
it may be the microbial population that
makes a huge differences in
collaboration with Indianapolis
University at the Purdue University
Indianapolis who is I upu I for short we
we made this study and and looked at the
local water to to really find what is
the microbial composition of this so the
samples were collected through a good
runner of the year at a very safe death
and location within the reservoir to
understand what microorganisms are
present and what is happening close the
treatment of outside so every year in
June actually may or june there is an
algaecide treatment to to get rid of
those ghetto bacteria and how it affects
the environment so when we look for
other
data you can actually already be as it
right in July at the bottom of the idea
of the lake and maybe I can show you
exactly where but this is it right here
so looking at this you can really tell
that it's a makes a difference and and
we wanted to study this a little bit
further so at that point we took that
data and move it to Antioch and the
empty bus is the metagenomics analysis
server this data was made on the on the
next week and we did multiple runs
wonderful most on under my feet and it
was the 16s using v3 v4 and then the
other says that we did was on the next
week and we did 11 11 of the samples on
to the next week shotgun to actually see
if we could see a difference when we
just at the variation at the bottom of
the lake we definitely saw different
within the SP no bacteria and and how it
changed the composition of the bacterial
also involved after the treatment of May
31st so the treatment was done on May
31st of 2016 and it caused the shift in
bacterial composition in the reservoir
the treatment is made of chemical
substances are dark specific to use to
control and kill algae and it's copper
base and we definitely need more
analysis on this finger but secures your
ship definitely show that the copper
treatment a release is causing a lot of
extra bathroom actually some speed
he asked about your low performance is
one of them and maybe there isn't
symbiotic relationship with with the
Athena bacteria and so because of the
person that we did this is beta with
wasn't interested in siena bacteria we
really focused on that and show the
changes during the year but now we can
we that data is available for anybody to
see on base base this collaboration is
still in progress and you can see how as
the secondi was able to identify the
presence of this microbes and observe
the shift in the environment for
treatment so definitely a plus and I
made that new clerk besides they're
working on on on this dataset so in any
month of your ecology of drinking water
its distribution system right now the is
usually the base of what if people are
doing is fingerprinting techniques right
doing pcr-based are giving a quick for
firing of spatial temporary variability
also fish sewers and in situ
hybridization can possess different
microorganisms submit similar mostly
using multiple floor and society but
sequence information is required for you
to be able to do the probe design while
doing the the next generation sequencing
so that we did for for example you don't
need to have a base right you can just
take a sample and sequence it all so
another way of studying that we have
honor on this scheme that I have up
there is cloning and sequencing but it's
time consuming and laborious so in a way
using my fee for the high
next generation sequencing is much
faster in less expensive than been
traditional tiger sequencing if you're
doing one run on just to look at a other
sample or a change throughout an
environment I believe that you know the
quality of water is something that is
very important and then GF should be
considered or will be considered as a
standard approach in the environment for
microbial research too because the
quality is coming in increasing and the
V length is is the cost is going down so
it should be considered as a standard
approach for environmental microbial
research definitely something that needs
to be done in creative water
distribution especially when you can
taste it so now I'm going to go into a
different approach which is message and
Omega N and animals the reason to two
different papers on there one of them is
how the microbiota of piglets actually
really influenced the glaciers disease
the Blazers disease is an infection
disease of pig and it can terrorized by
a combination of different bacteria and
this paper that I have right there use
the pen tablet from each of the farm is
that from different farm seven times
over a period of three to four weeks
this is 16s rrna and use it and runnin
on our devices to do the analysis we use
the chime software and then we're
looking at the UT use as the genus level
to see the overt express OT used in
papers from control farms and to see if
there was differences between there
the ones that were diseased or or not
this is the people really show how it
can be applied to any kind of of
metagenomic study it really showed the
difference of the bacterial communities
between the the figures that were fake
and the ones that did not get it you can
definitely see a game in proteobacteria
and the loss of her meet you when the
animal had the disease and so it really
helps characterize you know the strains
that are abundant when you have the
disease versus not and it could be a
useful tool for a non-invasive
prognostics tool in in those farms for
example that's that's one way to really
look at how to use a like this in
Aboriginal wig and it's devastating to
have those piglets but it is cost a lot
of money to those farms when the piglets
actually get it and it's very highly
contaminated it actually propagates very
very fast another paper that actually is
a very interesting it is the announces
of an outbreak of bovine service versus
in beef cattle and in white tail deer so
the to look at the this paper the they
did a lot of genotyping of isolates so
at that point they are actually
sequencing the full tuberculosis genome
providing whole genome sequencing of
tuberculosis and in this paper and in
the cattle and in this year and they're
trying to fish around
severe are the ones that are passing is
from 11 cattle set to another one so
whole genome sequence name really
confirmed the introduction of the
inflection into Minnesota and they look
at it and fell very little divergence
when they did this sequencing it is 19
isolate and covered two different sites
within the same animal earth same from
10 different animals and for years it's
cattle that were sequence 8 of the
animals had no detectable snaps
differences between the sites and two of
the animals however saw differences are
in indy TB so TV is a very highly
conservative bacteria so the way this is
set up is did the whole genome
sequencing DNA exhalation first and then
Disney mixer eggski so you can multiply
on to your my feet for immunity and then
he consent on the on the mic week and do
this data analysis this is that
difference the at that point you can
actually use paid as an assembler and
and then see the differences mapping
back one on to the others the conclusion
of this paper was a very interesting
because there is no strong correlation
between the fair was genetic emphasis
geographic distance so they couldn't
really tell whether the bovine and the
end this year really really shares the
same TV the the one in Mexico though
definitely different from the ones in
Michigan and also from the ones in
is over so it's a nice paper it really
explains how they really look at those
isolates and and map them back once it
the other looking at a way to look at
the message filmmaking in agriculture is
it's an interesting paper on the
evaluation of corn oil as an additive to
pre enrich Salmonella and secara from
Oregon oh so put for an outbreak of
Salmonella has been monitored by the FDA
and the CDC and the public health lab
all over the US quite a lot in the in
the past in the past I want to say three
years at lead the US has been monitoring
salmonella serovars and making sure that
the embraced are very different or or
involving the same thing and so they've
been noticing that in Oregon oh they
actually do find the same caliber they
found a limp outrage with cracked pepper
coating on on family of products and in
native a huge presence so this this
paper is actually really showing that by
by using a pre enrichment you can find
Salmonella for Mariano in in in a
shotgun approach so this is the third
approach that I wanted to show you today
which is just doing a shotgun and to
sequencing at all not not specializing
the way we did for 15 as design which is
put everything in and sequence at all
this this paper is really to develop a
better more efficient method in
isolating as salmonella from Oregon oh
and spices and be able to detect it
earlier in very small quantities because
that's one of the
is that you can't really tell it's there
because it's in such a small quantity so
when you look at the when you look at
the workflow that I have on this side
right here you you start with an
extraction the same way that I had it
before and then you followed by a
library preparation doing next era
against like that you can most less if
you want to and then sequencing it on
the leg c4 the high-speed because you do
need the coverage to be able to see your
samples and see very low amount of
Salmonella for example and then a
different ways of enough doing it
analysis one of them could be crackin
with a genomic or meta flange have
always of really looking at the data so
this is what i have and i think that
online we have a question yes thank you
so very much for your presentation we do
have those questions here lined up and
before we get started on the question
and answer session i would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions as we possibly
can with the time that we have all right
and we do have one question here that
actually has several parts to it so the
first part is in the water metod gnome
analysis how was the annotation of the
sequencing results done second part how
do you go from sequencing data to actual
identification of bacteria and then the
follow-up is that all done with base
space that's a very good question so for
the water sample that we've done I did
not do this in base base I actually more
is in mg bus and if you go to the mg R
Us website it really is friendly for
people that are not buying a
fermentation like me and and it really
takes the data so it takes all your
fescue files you have two important in
two mg R Us and it also asks you for all
the method data so if you have dates or
you know depths for example that's what
I had in mind you actually import this
from there the mg rest does take your
data and probably blast it through the
database that they have in there and
then at that point give you a gene list
so you do have you can have you can look
at it to Victoria list you have a
bacterial list and it gives you also the
abundance of them and then you also have
a gene list so it really has the
pathways for you laid out in there so i
would definitely and tell you to go
through mg rest for a first project base
base does have some apps that do this
for you to one of them that i mentioned
is crackin but it's not as proficient as
mg os's Kraken is one of them then you
would have to really look at the data a
different way and another thing is once
you have put it through Kraken you can
definitely also try to use proco as
another step within your analysis but
you have different ways of looking at it
the one that i did for the water i did
it through mgs perfect thank you so very
much I do have one final question here
for you what Illumina product is the
best for combination object products
that produce Salmonella infections so to
look at salmonella and the the best way
is to follow the FDA and the CDC
the call they are doing it through sorry
they are doing in through isolation so
they do do culture first if you go to
the FDA website you should be able to
find it actually the my see protocol it
is available for for everybody the teach
you how to culture it to start with
followed by doing the the library
preparation did you have a few
modifications to to the ones that I
showed you earlier and and then at that
point the the analysis that they use a
bio pneumatics but you could do it a
different way so one of them would be by
owner acts the same way that the FDA and
the CDC is doing it another way that I
was talking I touched a little bit on it
is using space to assemble the data and
then moving it through polka to see the
gene another way if you have multiple
strains you could do the assembly
through space and then move it to IG v
which is also available on base base for
you to compare one versus the other and
same thing I GP has a GUI so it really
you can pile up all your assembly is one
on top of the other and really see the
ship within the jeans and the end snips
also it's very visual it's actually a
software that was made by the road well
thank you so very much I'm just like to
go ahead and be sassy on it one last
time for any final questions and with
that would you be able to go ahead and
provide some final comments thank you
thank you so much for having me correct
fantastic well I just wanted to thank
him everyone for listening in today's
presentation and
there are no more questions here I would
like to go ahead and thank our sponsor
alumina for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December day you will see an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues we may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye